okay we are here with our YouTube Europe
team hey that's ed nor Jeff and Arvind
and tell us about what what's going on
here this is as described by one
prominent youtuber has been a sleeper
hit of novels this is a divorce question
which has been a fantastic innovation
between the World Economic Forum on
YouTube we have put the Darwins question
what is one thing that country's
companies or individuals can do to
change the world in 2008 out to the
general public out to the YouTube
community got some great responses and
we played these two world leaders here
and not only that but them all to
respond
as many as we can my place their own
responses to the demolition so guys who
have worked worked incredibly hard
pulling people in pulling leaders in and
the mansion really answers grinding them
to the ground get them up risk Jeff how
does it work tell me how this whole
thing works close all works as we sit
there and stare people's chests to see
their tag because we don't necessarily
recognize their face the shift 10 years
good look we have it oh that's a lot of
you so you as such as you poach people
know you're saying it's a nice way of
putting it and we go out there and you
look there you sit there too oh my
goodness who could that be that is bono
and then you wrestle him to the ground
which isn't very far away and you bring
him before it and then you hit play on
the record in your city answer the
goddamn question and then he does Arvind
what's the hit so far who's he who's
your favorite person has answered the
Davos question okay my favorite push and
personal favorite was Shimon Peres for
one reason because he sat in front of
the studio the computer he said hello
youtube and then he expected the
computer to ask you a question so you
did that and then add had to ask you the
question but that's my personal here
disguise his voice in it to make it
sound like the computer he pulled that
whole like 2001 Space Odyssey voice on
there but I got in all seriousness
though and we had Perez's posting and
then I mean Musa has responded directly
additional on Perez on YouTube and this
is the sitar users who are mimosas he's
the head of the arab league nations
thank ya and he
but to get that sort of interaction
between world leaders and in a bit of a
window to the YouTube community has just
been amazing so they've made some surely
prom with people here has been exposed
to youtube for the first time and
they'll be using it again so it's been a
huge ship and we hope the YouTube
community up there it's appreciated the
your thoughts of the world leaders most
influential people in the world we're
listening to you guys just like tonight